a few weeks ago i taught you how to
exploit the twitter algorithm to get a
six-figure job in tech but there's just
one major flaw with that strategy nobody
learning how to code has time to tweet
multiple times per day luckily you don't
have to because today i'll teach you how
to build a twitter bot from scratch that
uses artificial intelligence to create
unique high-value tweets all day long my
twitter bot bob is coming up with
awesome tweets at the top of the hour
every hour and i only pay him like 10
cents a day he tells funny jokes gives
web dev hot takes promulgates conspiracy
theories says nice things about his mom
and humble brags about his 100 days of
code journey he is my protege my magnum
opus when i die he will be the one to
carry the fire if you're new here like
and subscribe because in today's
tutorial you'll learn one of the most
important techniques in web development
today and that's how to work with the
oauth 2.0 authentication protocol as a
developer it opens the door to building
apps that act on behalf of a user from
another service like you might use it to
upload files to google drive process
payments with stripe connect or in our
case post tweets to somebody's twitter
account so before we jump into the code
let's do a quick crash course on api
authentication for twitter you'll first
want to create a developer account then
on the developer portal you can create a
new application when you create an app
it will give you an api key and api
secret the api key is like a username
while the secret is like a password
these two values together create what's
known as a bearer token to authenticate
your developer app this token is
included on an authorization header when
making a request to the api that tells
twitter who you are and what you have
access to that's nice and easy but it
just provides read-only access to public
information on twitter that's because
you don't automatically have access to
somebody else's account to get
permission from a user you'll need to go
through the oauth 2.0 authorization code
flow there are three steps in the
process on the server you'll first need
to create an authorization link that
will redirect the user to twitter where
they can grant access to your
application from the browser once
permission is granted twitter will then
redirect them to a different endpoint on
your server which is called the callback
url that url will also include a special
code that you'll need to verify on the
server once verified twitter will give
you two values an access token and a
refresh token you'll want to save these
values in a database the third step is
to use the access token that's the value
that gives you access to make api calls
on behalf of the user now the one
problem though is that the access token
will expire after a certain amount of
time it depends on what your app is
trying to do but if you want to post
tweets in the background while your user
is asleep then you'll also need to
refresh the token for that you make an
additional call to the twitter api with
your refresh token and it will respond
with a new access token this is a
security measure that prevents a hacker
from going absolutely crazy if your
database is ever compromised now that
you know how oauth 2.0 works let's
actually implement it with some
javascript code i'm going to use
firebase cloud functions for this
project but feel free to use any node.js
server that you want and also keep in
mind that if you're building a real
twitter bot you'll also need a database
to store the access tokens in this demo
i'll be using firestore to handle that
all you need is a firebase account which
is completely free and if you want to
get really good at firebase become a pro
member at fireship io i'll leave a
discount in the description to create a
new node.js project i'll first run
firebase init functions from the command
line lcd into the functions directory
and then install two dependencies we
have the twitter api node sdk and also
the openai sdk for gpt3 that we'll look
at later now in the index.js file we can
create multiple serverless functions
let's go ahead and do that for all three
steps in the process first we have auth
which will generate the authentication
link then we have the callback url and
finally we have an endpoint to do
something interesting with the api now
we're working in a trusted server
environment so i'm going to import
firebase admin and call admin initialize
app this will give us access to the
firestore database giving us a place to
store the access tokens in fact i'm
going to make a reference to a document
in the database right now which you can
think of as a json document that we read
and write to now from there we'll want
to initialize the twitter api there are
a few different ways to do it but in our
case using oauth 2.0 we'll want to
instantiate it using the client id and
client secret to get those values we'll
need to go back to our twitter app and
select oauth 2.0 from the authentication
settings now there is one very important
value that we'll need to add in the
configuration settings and that's the
callback url currently we don't have a
production url to use here but we can
create one by going to the terminal in
our project and running firebase serve
go ahead and copy the url that points to
callback then paste it into the twitter
app now twitter doesn't allow you to use
localhost but you can use your localhost
ip which is the same for everybody
127.0.0.1
now go ahead and save your settings and
it will give you a client id and client
secret those are the values you want to
use when instantiating the twitter
client i am also setting up a variable
here for the callback url because we'll
need to reference that later as well now
we're ready to implement step one we can
generate the authentication url by
running generate oa2 authlink it takes
the callback url as an argument and also
an array of scopes these are the various
permission levels that you're asking the
user to grant your app in this example
we want to be tweeting all day every day
which means we need read and write
access as well as offline access which
allows us to do things in the background
while the user is sleeping now calling
this method will return three values the
first one is the url we can take that
url and simply redirect the user to it
but in order to verify the user in the
future we'll also need to save a code
verifier and state to the database i can
do that with firestore by simply setting
those values on the document in the
database that's all there is to it let's
go ahead and try it out in the browser
when we go to the auth url it should
automatically redirect you to twitter at
this point you'll want to be signed into
the twitter account that you want to use
as the bot but what you'll also notice
is that if you go to the firestore
database you should see a value for code
verifier and state save there as well
when you click authorize notice how
twitter will redirect you to the
callback url and that url also contains
parameters for code and state now let's
implement the code to handle this
callback first we'll grab the state and
code values from the request query in
the url we need to compare these values
with what we stored in the database in
step one let's grab the code verifier
and the state from the database then run
a validation to see if there's a
mismatch between the state and the
stored state if they don't match then
we'll respond with an error otherwise we
can use the twitter client to log in
with oauth2 notice how it takes the code
from the url and the code verifier from
the database to authenticate the user
with our twitter app that will return an
authenticated client that we can use to
start making api requests on behalf of
that user but more importantly for now
it returns an access token and refresh
token which we'll also want to save in
the database now at this point we could
use the logged in client to make
requests to the twitter api we'll get to
that in just a second for now let's just
send a 200 response back and then go to
the browser and test it out after the
user is done granting permission via
twitter it should redirect to the
callback url at which point the access
and refresh tokens will be saved in the
database and now finally we've reached
the fun part of this video where we
outsource our tweets to artificial
intelligence via gpthree i would like to
invite you all to come along with me on
a journey
and the third endpoint the first thing
we'll do is access the refresh token
from the database now let's assume that
a few hours have passed and we want to
re-access the user's twitter account we
can do that by calling the refresh
oauth2token method which will give us a
brand new access token and also a client
where we can start making api calls when
we get the new access token we'll want
to also save that to the database
dealing with a refresh token is only
required if your twitter bot does things
in the background because otherwise your
app could just use the access token that
wouldn't be expired yet in any case we
can now use the twitter client to do
things like access the user's profile
information or to send a tweet on their
behalf and there's all kinds of other
things you could do as well like send
dms retweets or any kind of other
pointless activity you can imagine doing
on twitter for example let's go ahead
and use the client with version 2 of the
api to access their profile using the me
method that will give us some json data
which we can send as the response then
when we open the function in the browser
the result is an object with that user's
profile data now let's take things to
the next level with open ai you'll first
need an open ai account to access gpt3
then you'll need to grab your
organization id and api secret which are
then used to initialize the node sdk in
our javascript code now tweeting is
about to become the easiest thing you've
ever done in your life to create a new
tweet go back into the function code
then call openai create completion it
takes an ai model like davinci as its
first argument than a prompt as the
second argument if we prompt it to give
us a tweet it will generate a unique
tweet on the fly i want to point out
that in the full source code i did some
randomizing to give it over 10 000
potential prompts resulting in a greater
variation of tweets this code is top
secret to just me and bob but play
around with the prompt to see what kind
of interesting results you get now all
we have to do is take that text and then
call the tweet method on the twitter
client congratulations you just built an
ai powered twitter bot call this
function from the browser then go to
your twitter account and you should see
the new tweet posted there now all you
have to do is create a cron job to run
this in the background a few times a day
and after a few months you should have
all kinds of six figure job offers in
your dms if you found this tutorial
useful and want to build more complex
apps i have multiple articles and videos
for pro members on fire ship io
explaining different oauth 2.0
authentication flows and as a final note
i want to talk about who bob really is
like whose face is that it's not a
friend of mine or some random model i
found on the internet it's a face
generated with ai specifically a
generative adversarial network called
stylegan bob's face doesn't actually
exist in reality at least in the
biological sense check out
generated.photos to create your own
random person thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one